10 o'clock and
um
I believe we are ready to begin
the
joint fiscal committee
meeting of November 18th
uh could I have a motion to accept the
minutes
don't move
second
all right thank you Senator gray thank
you Senator Susie
okay uh all those in favor please
all those in favor please raise their
hand
opposed abstain
three abstentions
representative Emrick I believe
you are proposing that we take FIS 22
348 off the table
yes Madam chair and replaced with
replace it with 22 348 as we submitted
is there okay uh taking FIS 22 348 off
the table and replace it
with
22 348 revised correct revised the
replacement item for 348 correct okay oh
yes a replacement item for 348. thank
you representative erf
who made the motion I I did okay
hello planet Earth
all right uh good morning Tracy
uh is there anything you'd like to say
I know actually there were some
revisions uh that I think during the uh
proposal more in line
that's about it okay thank you are there
any other comments
seeing none while the clerk please call
the roll
22 340
years Emory votes yes representative erf
yes representative leishman
representative Lynn yes
Senator Birdsall
Senator Morris yes Senator gray yes
Senator Susie no
Senator Khan yes
representative umberger yes Madam chair
of the board is nine to one the vote
being nine to one
uh we have taken this off the table and
replaced it with 22 well with the
revised 22 348.
and uh
is there any discussion on the revision
seeing none will the clerk call the roll
of the item
second
oh
okay sorry uh representative erf made
the motion to approve representative
Leachman seconded
all right this 340 replacement
Emrick vote Yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
representative Lynn yes
Senator Birdsall
Senator Morris yes Senator gray yes
Senator Susie yes
Senator Khan yes
representative umberger yes Madam chair
the vote is 10-0 in favor
thank you the vote being 10-0 the motion
passes
Madam chair before we go any further
could I make a few comments certainly
thanks Madam chair
uh
often uh the committee will recognize
people at the very end of our meetings
or
losing uh at least two of the people
that are here today
Senator Morse and representative
umberger
and I don't know which one to start
first and either praise or but I'll
start with Senator Morris I became
friendly with Senator Morris when he was
a chair of Senate Finance
and I was chair of division one
and he called me up on the phone and he
said you know we need to speak about
what division one has done
so I I guess was a little timid at the
time because I heard a lot of tough
things about Chuck Morris but I ventured
over to his office and
I guess you could say that he knows how
many pencils
are purchased every year in the state
his knowledge of the budget is
incredible
um well he went through ours uh in
division one and he I guess he didn't
find any problems so I thought I guess I
passed his grade but over the years we
become friends and uh on a personal note
I lost my son
and I received a call from Senator
Morris and he said
I've got this beautiful
dogwood tree and I'm going to send a
group of people over and plant it so you
better find a place and my family and I
would like to honor you and your son
with the tree and that just speaks to
the gentleman sitting over there and I
I'm going to miss him because oftentimes
but not often but occasion will disagree
and I'll get that look even got the look
in the hall this morning because he saw
something I'd said in the newspaper so
I'm going to miss him and his State's
going to really lose an incredible
public servant but I'm sure somebody
will find a place for him but he's
certainly going to be missed and I thank
him for everything he's done for me in
the state and I'd like to move now to
Karen umberger who I met years ago she
came over to division one
and she was a rock as soon as she got
there I learned that she had been a
colonel in the Air Force and she often
kept me in line and some of the other
members of the division but Karen losing
Karen who is one of the most ethical
thorough individuals I've ever had the
privilege of knowing is uh it's a tough
day for again losing two very good
people in state government I just would
like to say thank you to them for their
service
[Applause]
thank you representative leishman I know
that both Senator Morris and I truly
appreciate
your words thank you
okay
moving now to the consent calendar
I have three items to take off consent
they are 22 399
22 404
and 22 385.
are there any other items to come off
consent
seeing none could I have a motion to
approve
the remaining items on the consent
calendar
thank you Senator gray and Senator
Birdsall seconded
you're not on
okay
this is on the consent calendar memory
quotes yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
representative uh Lynn yes Senator
Birdsall
Senator Morris yes Senator gray yes
Senator Susie
Senator Khan yes
representative umberger yes
uh Madam chair the vote is ten to zero
vote being 10-0 the remainder of the
consent calendar is approved
Madam chair if I might sorry Mike Kane
um what was the third item that was
removed from consent we got 399 404 and
385 385 thank you
okay moving on to the
um Regular calendar
if this is Tab 10
.
you want me to do that first okay all
right
Tracy wants me Tracy would prefer that I
go through the items that have been
taken off the consent calendar
nope we can do that all right uh
the first item is 22 399.
in tab I don't know what five
Madam chair yes I don't know if you're
going to order or not but the first one
if you go in order is 385. okay would
you also on top five I have no problem I
don't care either I just don't know
okay
385 FIS
22 385.
in tab 5.
good morning Nathan white DHHS CFO
good morning Trish Tilly director of the
division of Public Health Services
thank you both for being here yes
representative you have a question
thank you madam chair
can I start now yes you may my dad
thank you both for being here
um as I'm sure you're where I am pose
the question about parental consent as
it relates to this
um
physical mode and I have a question and
thank you for your responses to that um
but I'd like to go a little deeper in
that so given that Federal Essa law
which is the every student that succeeds
act requires and this is a quote from
that one very long document informed
consent from the parent of each child
who is under 18 years of age to
participate in any mental health
assessment or service
end quote wouldn't the more proactive
approach on the part of DHHS be to
actively encourage encourage the people
being trained to first get parental
consent when there's any concern on the
mental health of a child
I think that that's accurate and that
certainly can be if it is not currently
part of that training we can ensure that
that's part of that
are there any further questions
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll I'll move the item oh
thank you
irf and Lynn
I'm doing really well this morning
okay this is
uh 385.
Emory post yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
representative Lynn yes
representative Senator Birdsall Senator
Morris
Senator Susie yes Senator gray yes
Senator Khan yes senator umberger
yes
well you got a promotion today uh to the
little house uh Madam chair the vote is
ten to zero
the vote being ten to zero FIS 22 385
passes
we now turn to FIS 399
which is also in tab 5.
oh welcome back
I'm I'm still here and I'm also joined
by hi Ellen Lapointe uh CEO at New
Hampshire hospital okay someone had a
question representative Leachman thanks
Madam chair
good day good morning Mr White and I'm
sorry I didn't catch your name
Point oop
if I recall the tanks were supposed to
be removed some time ago and now it's
being put off again uh is your thoughts
that you will be bringing a request
through the budget to remove these tanks
again I guess yes yes that would be our
plan going forward
and a follow-up question certainly so
I'm taking it not to ever assume but
there's no environmental Risk by leaving
those tanks in the ground that's not an
issue it's just the abandoned tanks need
to be removed correct yes no
environmental risk associated with the
tanks okay uh thanks so much thanks
Madam chair that's all I have I'd move
the item if there's not another question
okay I have a motion
seconded by Senator Susie
will the clerk please call the roll on
oh another question
you might ask another question Madam
chair
sure after my Bocce in the first time
yeah
I'm sorry thank you madam chair could
you just so this was as I recall
approved in the
previous term not the current term
I'm just wondering why the two plus year
delay in even getting to the process
given that
doesn't wasn't like you had to plan
anything or you know do a design or
anything you're basically just taking
out tanks and putting in new ones
[Music]
I think so forgive me I I think that um
it was more recent that we got the
approval for the tanks
yeah so in um in in the attached to the
item in front of you
um we are actually this request is to
amend a prior item uh 22 162 that came
before the committee this past spring I
think I believe it was at the May
meeting where we were accepting uh what
was it about 5.6 million dollars of dish
funding and we had allocated uh funds to
specific projects and and the
underground oil tanks was one of those
projects and so here we're seeking to
repurpose those funds to cover the
additional inquiries construction costs
did I answer your question a follower
yes
um thank you for that sure but I thought
that item that you referred to was
actually
talking about an item that had been
previously budgeted in the prior term is
that not correct
the the the fist 22 162.
um that that item came before the
committee because it it did come outside
of the budget
hadn't the go ahead yes excuse me
I'll stop
okay we have a motion on the floor by
representative leishman seconded by
Senator Susie
will the clerk please call the roll
roll on 399 Emrick votes irf yes
representative uh
Lynn yes
Senator bird cell
Senator Morris
Senator gray yes Senator Susie yes
Senator Khan
no
representative umberger uh yes
oh Do Right representative leishman yes
sir
we're supposed to be organized in our
last meeting of the Year we're not doing
well
Madam chair of the vote is nine to one
the vote being nine to one FIS
uh 399
passes
we now turn to FIS
22 404
under
tab
seven
I'm sure
I'd like to make a motion to table
22 404 for a special meeting on December
2nd
Madam chair before we do that may I uh
it's we can table it first and then you
can make your announcement okay all
right uh do I have a second for that
second thank you representative Leachman
uh representative Lynn needs to make a
statement
yes uh thank you madam yes
this is not a debate this is simply a
statement based on his
um
involvement
okay just so it's clear for everybody
thank you thank you madam chair I I uh I
make this disclosure pursuant to the
general Court's ethics uh booklet part
one section seven uh and I do this not
because I believe that I really have a
conflict of interest but nonetheless out
of an abundance of caution I know that
yesterday I filed a declaration of
intent
with respect to this matter it arises
out of the fact that there has uh there
apparently is a dispute between some
parties relating to the matter one of
the parties being Comcast and I note for
the record that I own and have owned for
many years uh shares of Comcast uh
common stock of approximately uh as of
checking as of yesterday was 243 shares
those shares represent
a small percentage of the assets held by
my myself and my wife and I do not
believe that um
I have no question that it would not
affect in any way my ability to fairly
and impartially consider the matters in
related to this issue nor do I believe
that any person any objective person
fully informed of the facts could
conclude otherwise for those reasons I
do not intend uh I intend to participate
in the vote on this matter and I as I
said I have filed a written Declaration
of intent with the clerk of the house
thank you thank you very much
will the clerk please call the roll on
FIS 404 404 tabled until December 2nd
Emery votes yes representative Earth yes
representative leishman yes
representative Lynn yes
Senator Birdsall
Senator Morris
Senator gray yes
Senator Susie yes Senator Khan
yes
representative umberger yes Madam chair
the vote is 10 to zero thank you very
much the vote being ten to zero this
item is tabled and we will have a
special meeting on December 2nd to fully
discuss this item
okay now can I go to the regular
calendar thank you thank you we now turn
to tab 10.
the first item on the agenda is FIS 22
395 the Department of Health and Human
Services
good morning Nathan white CFO DHHS good
morning
are there any questions for Mr White
seeing none
could I have a motion
representative erf do I have a second
by representative Lynn
will the clerk please call the roll
on 395. Eric votes yes representative
erf yes representative leishman yes
representative Lynn yes Senator Birdsall
Senator Morris
Senator gray yes
Senator soucy yes Senator Khan yes
representative umberger yes Madam chair
of the vote is 10 to zero the vote being
ten to zero FIS 22 395 passes
we now turn to FIS 22 392.
uh
this item was a change to a form
for the YDC Center
settlement
you have a copy of the change in your
books
are there any comments
seeing none of the item thank you
representative Lynn do I have a second
thank you Senator Gray
ready okay
all right please call the roll 392.
primary votes yes representative yes
representative leishman yes
representative Lynn yes Senator bird
cell
Senator Morris
Senator gray yes Senator Susie yes yes
Senator Khan yes
representative umberger yes Madam chair
the vote is 10 to zero the vote being
ten to zero FIS 22 392 is approved
turning to tab 12
FIS uh 22 380 from the office of the
governor
go ahead would you please introduce
yourself
I you need yeah thank you good morning
my name is Amy Clark and I'm with the
Department of Education I'm the
administrator for school safety and
facility management
good morning Rob Buxton director of
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management
uh welcome I have not met you before so
congratulations on your new job thank
you
are there any questions for either of
the folks here
seeing none could I have a motion please
thank you represent second advice
seconded by Senator Birdsall
uh by the way not all go through this
easy I just I just want you to know that
and that uh this is only because it's
your first time we allowed it to happen
I appreciate it no problem this is your
freebie
uh this is on 380. Emery boats yes
representative erf yes represent
leishman yes representative Lynn yes
Senator Birdsall yeah Senator Morris
Senator gray yes Senator Susie
Senator Khan
represent umberger yes Madam chair of
the vote is ten to zero the vote being
10-0 FIS 380 passes thank you
we now turn to tab 13.
uh
FIS
22373 from Fish and Game
yeah blah blah stop we can't hear you
because your mic's not on
good morning Madam chair members of the
fiscal committee my name is Lieutenant
Robert Mancini with the New Hampshire
Fish and Game department
thank you
are there any questions from the
committee
seeing none representative Leachman
moves FIS 22373
seconded by representative Emrick
a roll call on 373 Emrick votes
representative erf yes representative
leishman yes representative Lynn yes
Senator bird cell Senator Morris Senator
gray yes Senator Susie yes Senator Khan
yes representative umberger yes and I'm
sure the vote is ten to zero the vote
being ten to zero FIS 22 373 passes
we now turn to FIS
22389 also from Fish and Game
Lieutenant I see you have someone that
has joined you
okay
Scott Mason the executive director of
fish and game thank you
are there any questions from the
committee
seeing none could I have a motion to
accept FIS
22389 don't move
thank you represent Lynn seconded by
Senator Gray
roll calling 389 Hamrick votes yes
representative erf yes representative
leishman yes representative Lynn yes
Senator Birdsall yes Senator Morris
Senator gray yes Senator soucy yes yes
Senator Khan yes representative umberger
yes Madam chair of the vote is 10-0 the
vote being 10-0 FIS 22 389 pass
thank you both for coming in today
we now turn to tab 14
which is FIS 22391.
foreign
yes welcome
okay
that's all right just turn your
microphone on and introduce yourself
yeah good morning my name is David King
I'm the administrative judge of the New
Hampshire Circuit Court
are there any questions on FIS 22 381
perfect timing
representative Lynn yes uh to either the
Chief Justice or Justice King am I
understanding that you are submitting
this for the purpose of of us being
aware of it not not to sort of bless it
so to speak
um
and I think I mean personally the reason
for that is I we really haven't had a
chance to look at it in any in the
underlying we got the underlying report
um yesterday uh and I haven't had a
chance to really look at it
um
and the one thing that I I say candidly
the one thing that at least raises a
question in my mind is um the with
regard to the Circuit Court the need for
21 additional judicial officers that I
mean I I don't have any question that
you may need some additional Circuit
Court judges I don't have any question
about that 21
is I guess I'd like to
if you're asking us to sort of say we
agree with that I think I wouldn't be
prepared to do that now
uh good morning Madam chair members of
the committee uh for the record I'm
Gordon McDonald chief justice with me is
uh the administrative judge of the
Circuit Court David King we're here as
required under RSA 490 Colonel 11 to
submit uh for the committee's approval
uh awaited caseload study so we're we're
here pursuant to the legislature's
directive the way to caseload study for
the benefit of the members of the
committee
is an evidence-based uh study based on a
very a well-established methodology
um and
um
you know the the be happy to react to uh
the the
um
the findings of the study but it is
something that we undertook in
consultation with the national group
that is done
um
many of these studies and um
uh in in the conclusions are what they
are
did you have a follow-up yeah I guess
what I'm I I guess all I'm sort of
saying is I'm not at least personally
I'm not
I'm not prepared to to sort of accept it
at this point I'm not yeah it may very
well be able to be you know be entirely
appropriate to accept it all I'm saying
is I don't think I've had enough time
and I'm not sure if any of the other
members of the fiscal committee have
really had enough time to digest the UN
you know the the full report to make a
decision on it now that's that's all I'm
really saying
are there any further questions
I I do have I do have one question
um
when you submit your budget
which is coming up relatively soon uh
will you be including these new
positions in your budget the uh we we
have submitted the budget to the
governor and the the our budget does
reflect
uh what we learned from the way to
caseload study but I will tell the
committee it does not reflect all the
positions that were set forth in the way
the case would study
and and just
um if I may man I'm sure getting back to
uh representative Lynn's
question that specifically what the uh
statute asked the committee to approve
are any revisions to the weighted case
values so we're not that's technically
what you're approving the the revisions
to weighted case values and not
necessarily the number of positions that
that those case values
um
are suggesting are needed
okay are there any further questions
okay thank you Senator Susie
seconded by Senator Birdsall
will the clerk please call the roll
roll call 391 emric votes yes
representative erf yes representative
leishman yes representative Lynn now
Senator Birdsall yes
Senator Morris
that was yes yes okay Senator gray no
uh Senator basusi yes
Senator Khan yes
representative umberger yes Madam chair
of the vote is eight yes two no the vote
being eight in favor and two opposed FIS
22 391 is approved
thank you madam chair members of the
committee and and
obviously please reach out to me or
judge king as you study the report and
be happy to respond to any questions
thank you very much
we now turn to FIS 22
374 from the state treasury
that is in tab 15.
please
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee for the record I'm Monica
Mississippi State Treasurer okay okay
thank you
uh
are there any questions for the
treasurer
seeing none could I have a motion please
thank you
motion by Senator Susie second by
Senator Khan
let me call him 374. Henry votes yes
representative erf
yes representative leishman yes
representative Lynn yes
senator robertsell
Senator Morris
Senator gray yes Senator soucy yeah
Senator Khan yes representative umberger
yes Madam chair the vote is ten to zero
vote being ten to zero FIS 22 374 is
approved thank you
Mr Kane
sure just um on that I would
we can get to it during the audits for
release of the kafir and all the the
annual reports uh you do have four late
items that you need to take up you have
three from the governor's office uh the
Gopher
uh office and you also have one from
Employment Security and one from
administrative services
so you probably want to take actions on
those first before the audits are
presented today I'll have uh ask
representative Emrick to make that
motion to release the other reports okay
so you'll release some oh okay yes when
we do the audits yes sir okay no problem
thank you I was confused
that was my fault thanks okay
um
we now move to the
[Music]
um
informational items
and I would like to say that FIS 22 375
from the Department of Health and Health
and Human Services
was an excellent report and I I
appreciate it
I also felt that FIS 22 376
from oh from the Department of Health
and Human Services was also a very good
report
so if we could now
go to
relate items
if I can find them
but they're in your manila folder
okay
thank you
4.3 okay
I guess I must have left behind every
other rooms
okay
our first item on the uh late items is
FIS 22
from uh the governor's office for
emergency relief and Recovery
please
good morning
can you hear me okay yep
and I'm sorry uh which item is this now
uh
423 423
this is emergency rental assistance okay
thank you
so quick explanation so
um please thank you uh so this item uh
is related to a situation that we have
been dealing with with the
um emergency rental assistance program
as you know and we've discussed in this
uh Forum many times uh there are
resources that have been provided to
this fed to to the state from the
federal government we have been spending
those resources uh pretty quickly over
the last couple of years in uh I uh
with a sub award agreement through New
Hampshire housing as we now are seeing
the end of the funding that is available
to the state under this program we have
a number of people who are at this point
being temporarily housed in hotels and
motels in the state
what we have in front of you today is a
request to fund the uh from the the
state's fiscal Recovery Fund to in the
amount of 20 million dollars to continue
to provide housing for those individuals
through April 15th April 1st excuse me
for individuals and couples and through
June 15th for a cup for families we feel
that this is the uh the population that
is in the most needy situation going
into the winter months the timing in
terms of the availability of resources
under era and the uh the diminishing
amounts that are available to that is
not of our is not of our preference we
have over the last couple of months made
requests from U.S treasury in excess of
100 million dollars worth of
reallocation reallocated funds under the
era program to continue funding the full
program but to date we have received
somewhere just above four million
dollars worth of funds for them for that
reallocation
um so this is uh this is an opportunity
for us to take care of the people that
are in the most needy situation as we go
into the winter months keep them in a
housing situation we will continue to
work with those individuals through New
Hampshire housing in the caps
with the services that will be provided
to them to help them transition a more
permanent housing situation and also get
them access to other services that are
available at the state and federal level
those have been underway since the
Inception of this program and we'll
continue so a combination of 20 million
dollars for that purpose in addition I
believe there's a separate item for
um for the services that will go with
does with those programs so that's I
guess the quick overview Madam chair
okay thank you
uh represent leishman thanks Madam chair
thanks for your presentation
commissioner
so I believe we've got about 7 500
families I don't know what that equates
to as far as individuals and clearly I
support keeping them out of the winter
cold but what concerns me I understand
that we're paying as much as 350 or more
dollars to hotels for rooms or are you
able to control some of those costs
paying those higher rates would
certainly eat into your funding
absolutely and and thank you
representative our goal with this round
of funding that we are asking for now
the 200 the 20 million we are going to
uh set sort of a uh an overall goal of
200 as a cap for uh the per night cost
of of these of this type of housing I
think though uh having said that we are
going to have some instances where we
might see in the upper in the Mount
Washington Valley for instance where the
cost of a hotel room during February
vacation week is a higher amount and we
don't want to put anyone in the position
of going in and out of a housing
situation and so we're going to build in
an ability to have some flexibility but
then again when we get into the March
and April shoulder season we would
expect to see that number decrease
as you know in in terms of the
availability of hotel rooms for other
people than the ones that we're housing
under the program follow-up yes thanks
Madam chair
it would seem to me if you're filling up
these hotels and motels during the off
season that that rate should carry
forward
consistently because you're providing
that funding to keep those rooms full
even though there may be a week you know
in the February school vacation I would
think would be advantageous for those
facilities to have their rooms full for
the entire winter yep and keep the rate
pretty constant that would be certainly
my hope I absolutely agree with that but
I think you know we we can't foresee
that there would not be a situation
where we would have to have
um you know a hotel that is
willing to switch people out I don't
necessarily want to put ourselves in
that position I want to be able to
continue to have them house those
individuals for a period of time where
there goes above a a loose cap let's say
a flexible cap
um but overall yes we our our goal is to
keep the overall spend rate on the
program at 200 or less thank you thank
you madam chair are there any further uh
thank you uh Senator Khan thank you
madam chair and uh following on the same
uh tangent the
who is going to set that rate
and is that the Caps that are going to
be responsible for whatever rate cap
the Gopher sets for reimbursement yes
Center so that's what's happening right
now so bear in mind that this is not
necessarily a whole new thing there are
people who are currently in hotels and
they're being paid for under the the era
program
this is an extension of that program
with guidelines that will include an
effort to keep the per day per night
rate under 200 dollars
thank you are there any further
questions
seeing none could I have a motion please
thank you represent leishman second
Senator Khan
will the clerk please call the roll
we'll call on four two three here make
boats yes representative Earth yes
representative leishman yes
representative Glenn yes rep Senator
Birdsall yes Senator Morris
Senator gray yes Senator Susie Senator
Khan yes representative umberger yes
Madam chair the vote is 10-0 the vote
being ten to zero
FIS 22 423 passes
turn now to FIS 22 224 also from the
governor's office for emergency relief
and Recovery
dealing with housing stability services
or 24.
thank you uh Madam chair so this item as
I mentioned uh a moment ago is in
concert with the funding that we've
requested for uh uh for the hotel
situation this is housing stability
Services
um we will be working with New Hampshire
Housing and the Community Development
Finance Authority uh and sub Awards to
continue in large part programs that
they already have operating that will
allow us to expand and maintain service
to these communities in our hotel and
motel over the over the course of the
winter to put them in a position for
success for finding more permanent
housing
there are within their two two primary
programs that deal with Outreach and
education to landlords and and then
other programs to make be sure that
these populations are able to get
connected to existing financial services
but also for mental health and sud
treatment
the total is 3.2 3.3 million dollars
uh are there any questions from the
committee
seeing none could I have a motion please
thank you Senator Grace seconded by
Senator Susie
oh the clerk please call the roll
we'll call on 424. Henrik votes yes
representative erf yes representative
leishman yes representative Lynn yes
Senator burso yes Senator Morse Senator
gray yes Senator Susie Senator Khan
representative umberger yes Madam chair
the vote is 10-0
the vote being ten to zero FIS 22
420 424 passes
we now turn to FIS 22425.
also from the governor's office for
emergency relief and Recovery
thank you madam chair this final item uh
is around 2.2 million dollars this is a
a reallocation under the era2 program so
as you heard me mention before we've
received a total reallocations around
4.4 million dollars this is 2.2 of that
that U.S treasury has provided this
funding will go directly into the
existing era program it is not exclusive
to the hotel motel uh funding that that
we just discussed so this is just merely
a reallocation there were two items that
you passed under one or two items that
you passed under consent that do the
same thing for era and era2 this one
just came in just late so we wanted to
make sure that we got it through
so this will go into the total pot of
funding that's available under the
existing era program
are there questions
I do have one yes ma'am
um with this additional funding will the
rental assistance go beyond 29 December
or 31 December whatever that date is I
think what this does really is it gives
us much more of a cushion uh in that
time period
um I I I don't recall the the weekly
amount that that is being spent at this
point but two million dollars is going
to get us I think a couple extra days
we're doing about five million dollars a
week in rental subsidy right now
so then what happens
what what happens to the families that
we're providing rental assistance to so
for so as we've just discussed the
people that are in that situation in
hotels and motels and I'm not talking
about the hotels and motels I'm talking
people that are in other programs where
they're in the lease department or
there's some other situation uh there
we've been rotating people on and off
that program since the Inception of this
program uh so people have either time
limitations as to how much time they can
actually are eligible for under the
program or uh they uh they'll cycle in
and out of a given apartment
um so in all of those cases it is a bit
of a constant transition uh and but also
in each of these cases the caps and New
Hampshire housing are continuing to
provide these services to help people
find housing and in a lot of cases
that's why they're leaving the program
is because they are able to find a
location somewhere in the state
and uh and and not have to be on the
subsidy program but but I think the fact
is is that at this stage the rental
subsidy program not related to hotels
and motels is winding down at this point
so if I might
um
on the
rental assistance side of it
um
are the Caps expecting
people to have to move out of apartments
and into hotels and motels
that that is we we're not gonna I don't
think we'll see a lot of that type of
activity uh we have other programs that
we have in place for individuals and
families that are caught in a situation
where they have uh either
um uh eviction issues or other mental
issues uh whether it's through funding
that we have provided and you've
approved through the court system uh to
mediate those situations uh in
combination with the support services uh
you know I think given the resources
that we have available to us to continue
to assist these families
um that's uh really at the at the peak
of the activity right now is uh
continuing to provide those Services
okay thank you are there any further
questions
uh representative Leachman
thank you madam chair
so I just have one I hope simple
question your explanation is a little
lean and how many people are involved in
these programs like your supportive
staff and what's the cost of supporting
these programs on the state or on the
Federal Grant
so this program is administered by New
Hampshire Housing and uh and then they
work with the cap agencies in terms of
the specifics on the administrative
costs I might ask Chase to to give you
that
sure uh Chase Hageman deputy director at
gopher
um that's a good question representative
the contract overall for rental
assistance has effectively a cap on
administrative costs I believe it's
eight and a half percent total split
between New Hampshire Housing and the
caps and then when it comes to the
support of services there's a similar
administrative cost that goes that's
built into those contracts but as you
might expect a lot of the con those kind
of services are very Personnel intensive
so a lot of it is Staff costs to work in
the case management setting specifically
thanks
are there any uh Senator Khan yeah thank
you madam chair just
how many families are currently being
served by this program I mean with one
month left to go I
I I'm sure they're going to be working
hard but uh to to make sure that they
don't hit the cliff but how many people
are we talking about how many families
so Sandra it's also a good question
overall the program has served over 25
000 households from what I recall of the
numbers that's typically around I think
2500 families a week benefiting from
this program uh and then there are
several hundred that are also in house
or in hotels and motels at this point
which is why this funding is coming
before you today uh in terms of a
specific set number every week it
depends especially as New Hampshire
Housing and the Caps continue to process
the applications that have come in as of
the application pause on October 21st so
right now it's it's less about
weekly quote burn rate but assessing the
final population of applications that
have come in
I I from what I recall that was the
average
um number of households on a weekly
basis that were benefiting in some way
from the program
are there further questions
seeing none could I have a motion
to accept
representative Lynn moves Senator gray
seconds
we'll call on 425 Emery poach yes
representative erf yes representative
leishman yes representative Lynn yes
Senator Birdsall yeah Senator Morris yes
Senator gray yes Senator soucy yes
Senator Khan yes representative
munberger yes Madam chair the vote is
10-0
the vote being 10-0 FIS 22
425 passes
thank you very much
we'll now turn to FIS 22
426 from the Department of Employment
Security
foreign good morning Madam chair Richard
lavers Deputy Commissioner at the New
Hampshire Department of Employment
Security
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee Justin cutting with the
Department of Safety safety's division
of fire standards and training and EMS
the
okay
uh would you mind going through and just
explaining what this what you're asking
for absolutely Madam chair so uh the the
request before the committee is to use
two and a half million dollars
approximately of State fiscal recovery
funds for a targeted Workforce
recruitment program for our emergency
transportation providers in the state so
the providers we're talking about are
all licensed with the Department of
Safety and includes it includes your
your ambulance providers it includes
your your public fire departments it
includes some Emergency
Medical Service units that are in the
the private sector as well so are about
300 employers Statewide that are
licensed to provide this service for
emergency and non-emergency
transportation I mean what we're seeking
to do is to add additional emergency
medical technicians to their ranks
currently we have about 2 600 EMT
certified and licensed individuals in
the state the department of safety has
identified a shortage in that field
which then has a compounding effect
throughout the health care delivery
system so when we don't have enough EMTs
to be providing transportation for
individuals not only to get to our
health care facilities in an emergency
situation that's a problem but it is
also a problem when we don't have
sufficient EMTs to provide that
transportation between facilities so
from a hospital to a rehabilitation
facility or long-term care facility so
this program would address that
Workforce issue in three ways very
targeted way
it would first provide funding to those
licensed employers to to pay for the
cost associated with EMT certification
and licensure for individuals seeking
that basic level of EMT certification
and that would also pay that cost
associated with certification for
advanced EMT as well we would also
provide funding to those employers to
provide some relief on some of the wage
pressures of current practice right now
is that such an employer would be
reluctant to hire an individual prior to
obtaining that basic level of EMT
certification this program would provide
a 50 percent wage reimbursement for
those licensed employers during the four
weeks of employment while they are
obtaining that basic level EMT
certification and licensure and as a
third component this program would also
provide a recruitment and retention
incentive to individuals uh try to add
additional people again who will have
that basic level of EMT certification
and provide them with a thousand dollar
payment upon completion of that EMT
certification and uh sticking with that
employer for six months so we're trying
to do this in a very targeted way with
these two and a half million dollars of
State fiscal recovery funds however we
do feel that targeting this particular
group within the health care delivery
system will provide some much needed
relief for these emergency
transportation services throughout the
Health Care system
thank you very much are there any
questions
representative
I thank you madam chair
regarding the training time period for
which you're paying the wages or half
the wages my understanding is the
training programs tend to run more like
three months not not four weeks
so we're we're being very
um
recognizing that we have a limited
amount of dollars here
um
we're looking at uh providing that
relief for the the four weeks
um and
um
looking at what the current constraints
are and talking with that employer
Community we feel that will provide
sufficient relief on the wage side to
allow that that higher prior to what is
current practice right now so it is
limited to that four weeks while that
individual is engaged in training in
terms of the customary length of that
training I could turn over here to
director cutting to talk a little bit
about that
thank you excuse me thank you
representative so some employers will
their intent is to go out recruit a
group of individuals to receive this
training and then excuse me could you
yeah I apologies certain employers
intend to go out and recruit individuals
to become employees and then they are
going to sponsor a specific condensed
class which puts it into that four or
five week time frame the typical time
frame is three to four months but that
is a nights and weekend type of program
which I don't believe would
fall under the wage reimbursement
portion but would serve a lot of the
small communities throughout the state
are there further questions
seeing none could I have a motion please
Senator Birdsall moves to accept and
Senator soucy seconds
could the clerk please call the roll
call on 426. Henrik votes representative
erf yes representative leishman yes
representative Glenn yes representative
Birdsall yes I'm Senator I'm sorry
Senator Morse
Senator gray yes Senator soucy yes
Senator Khan yes representative umberger
yes Madam chair the vote is 10-0 the
vote being 10-0 FIS
22 426 passes thank you thank you very
much
okay we now turn to FIS
22427 from the Department of
administrative services
hi
uh Charlie Arlington the commission of
administrative Services
um I'll try to be brief uh first of all
sorry it's late
um this came up uh kind of last minute
as you know we our function on
Recruitment and Retention is essentially
ministerial so
a small number of people have these sort
of uh payments throughout the state none
of them work for me
throw that out there
um
in looking at the implementation of this
program a couple of the agencies who
have the larger bonus programs found
anomalies and the urgency is dictated by
winter maintenance as you may be aware
winter is essentially upon us
um and we need people to plow there was
a provision in the original language
that excluded people who were out on
leave out on an extended leave it was
determined uh operationally and the
Departments will have details if you
really need them but essentially you
know let's say you're out because you uh
because you sprained your ankle and
you're off on workers comp for two weeks
do we really not want you do we not want
to retain you plowing if you're just
coming back from maternity leave and
you're missing out on the first month or
so we still want you on board a plowing
a truck or whatever it is whatever it is
that we need done and so in doing so
this is essentially tweaking the
language so there's not an automatic
exclusion of a certain group of people
who may have legitimate reasons for
being out and it allows a proration of
the uh of the amounts for those people
and that in discussions with the other
agencies that are in this program safety
and Corrections Etc
um uh common language was identified and
then
um
I know I got it Tuesday and
um and you gratefully accepted it uh
coming forward but it just makes the
program more operational and it
eliminates a minor glitch and allows to
prorate
thank you are there any questions or
commissioner arlinghaus
en is uh yeah refresh
how how are the are the programs working
are we retaining people is it seeming to
work um I think we are I think the proof
um I think it's too early to declare
success because this is sort of the
front end what we really want to do is
keep people through the for example
winter maintenance through the winter
season and I can tell you the answer to
that when Winter's over and people
didn't leave and so I think it's too
early to say
hmm
are there any further questions I
noticed uh commissioner Shaheen nodding
her heads oh that's good
I'm scared to Look Backwards oh okay
only forward-looking today okay are
there any further questions
seeing none could I have a motion to
accept Senator Gray
seconded by Senator Susie
roll call on 427 Emery poets yes
representative erf yes representative
leishman yes representative Flynn yes
Senator Birdsall yeah Senator Morse yes
Senator gray yes Senator Susie
Senator Khan yes representative umberger
yes Madam chair the vote is 10-0 the
vote being 10-0 FIS 427 passes thank you
Madam chairman can I if I could be
inappropriate for a second
um I'm seeking for myself but I suspect
most agencies would agree with me on
this I was distressed to hear that you
were taking a sabbatical
um and uh uh from the standpoint of
those of us on this side of the table I
would say that your unfailing
professionalism that your knowledge of
operational details in your general good
cheer has made fiscal a pleasure and so
I appreciate it and thank you for your
service thank you very much
foreign
I just want to make a couple of comments
before we get to the audits and this has
to do with the information items so that
folks understand that um
at least I have gone through and read
them and am
you know recognize
when something is good
I was glad to see that our health
insurance is still solvent and
going in the right direction
I also in
on the in Department of administrative
Services the quarterly status report
I would like to say that um
I did have some questions the folks from
LBA followed up with the agencies
and I would like to remind all of the
agencies that it's much better to
provide the information up front than it
is to
provide the information on the back end
but anyhow thank you for uh for that
report
um
okay
oh yeah probably
uh Madam chair I moved that today's
audits as well as any any additional FY
2022 annual Financial reports which
become available prior to the end of the
calendar year be accepted placed on file
and released to the public in the usual
manner
I think
seconded seconded by Senator Gray
and we need to have
a vote
okay
this is the vote on accepting reports
Emrick votes representative erf yes
representative leishman
stepped out representative Flynn yes
uh Senator Birdsall yeah
uh Senator gray yes Senator Susie yes
Senator Khan yes representative umberger
uh yes
Madam chair the vote is eight to zero
vote being eight to zero the motion
passes
okay
did I forget something
no I'll do it at the next one
okay
my friends from the audit division
I understand you have uh all kinds of
exciting things for us today that we can
hardly wait on
no good morning Madam chair members of
the committee for the record Steve Smith
director of audits for the LBA we're
here to present uh first of all the
financial audit that we did on the
Department of Business and economic
affairs
for the nine months ended March 31st uh
Christine Young a senior manager with
our office was the in charge on this
audit she will present our report and
also joining us from the Department is
commissioner Caswell will be available
for questions
hmm
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee
for the record my name is Christine
Young and I will be presenting the
report on our financial audit of the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs for the nine months ended March
31st 2022.
this report is presented in two sections
the first section is the management
letter section prepared by the Auditors
and it contains our report on internal
control and compliance along with 16
audit observations
in the second section the financial
section contains our independent
Auditor's report followed by the
department prepared financial statement
and notes
you will not find a section in this
report containing the current status of
Prior audit findings since the
department is a fairly new state agency
established on July 1st 2017 and this is
the first time our office has conducted
an audit of the department
the focus of my presentation will be on
the observations and recommendations
however we'd be happy to answer any
questions you may have regarding any
part of this report
if you turn to the table of contents the
report includes eight internal control
comments two of which are material
weaknesses and eight State compliance
comments
the department concurs fully or in part
with all the findings
there are seven findings marked with an
asterisk
suggesting that legislative action may
be required
the discussion of the observations and
recommendations begins on page three
yeah
observation number one is a material
weakness Excuse excuse me on the
um you're recommending
um
legislative action yes
uh
what do we have two more days
on the on the house side
and we have a little bit longer on the
Senate side
okay but if something requires
legislative action
uh commissioner you need to work with
someone on the Senate side to
to get that
moving forward so that we don't end up
forgetting it so
yeah okay fine all right I'm sorry to
interrupt but that's okay but I wanted
to make sure that I got that out so that
we're not uh running into a
problem that can be blamed on the
legislature okay thank you
observation number one is a material
weakness and it discusses risk
assessment
which is one of the five recognized
components of internal control
we recommended the department establish
and document a formal risk assessment
process and review for indicators of
risk exposure
observation number two on page four is
also a material weakness and it reports
the department did not pay invoices in a
timely manner resulting in
non-compliance with State policies and a
1.2 million dollar expenditure posting
error in New Hampshire first
observation number three on page six
discusses the need to perform and
document a review and approval procedure
for certain federal drawdowns processed
by the department
in observation number four on page six
we recommended the department strength
and controls over the processing of
transfers of personnel expenditures to
ensure the recording and reporting of
complete and accurate financial
information
in observation number five on page eight
we noted the department was not in full
compliance with State policy or the
provisions of mousse it entered into
with certain state agencies
observation number six on page nine
reports on weaknesses noted over the
collection of revenues in the
Department's Bureau of visitor services
in observation number seven on page 11
we noted the department has not
established an I.T plan a disaster
recovery plan or business continuity
plan which are critical to the
Department's financial accounting and
Reporting process
observation number eight on page 12
discusses instances where employees had
New Hampshire first system access
permissions that were outside the scope
of their job responsibilities
page 13 is the start of the state
compliance comments
observation number nine reports the
department has not established a state
development plan as required by Statute
the plan is to identify critical issues
facing the state determine the state's
priorities in limited resources and
collaborate with others on the physical
social and economic growth and
development of the state among other
things
the next three observations observations
number 10 through 12 starting on page 14
report on compliance issues that are
frequently reported on in our financial
audits such as the need to adopt
administrative rules
non-compliance with statements of
financial interests and the need to file
statutory reports
in observation number 13 at the top of
page 18 we note the department has not
established the Broadband matching Grant
initiative according to statute
effective July 1st 2021 to provide
matching grants to broadband providers
and others to improve Broadband
availability across the state
observation number 14 on page 18 reports
the department has not implemented the
New Hampshire college graduate retention
incentive partnership program
established in statute to raise
awareness of an incentive available to
college graduates
observation number 15 on page 20
discusses the covid-19 micro Enterprise
Relief Fund which was established in
statute on June 25th 2021 to protect the
economic health and sustainability of
New Hampshire entities with 10 or fewer
employees known as micro Enterprises
the department has not implemented or
used the fund
lastly observation number 16 on page 20
describes some housekeeping issues
regarding outdated statutes that should
be reviewed to ensure alignment with the
Department's organizational chart and
accounting and Reporting structure
the financial section of the report
follows with our Auditor's opinion which
was modified as a complete set of
financial statements was not presented
the statement of revenues and
expenditures is on page seven followed
by the notes to the financial statement
we also included a one-page letter with
the report this is a required
communication to governance to inform
you that a material adjustment to the
accounting records was proposed and
recorded as a result of our audit
that concludes my presentation I'd like
to thank commissioner Caswell and his
staff for their cooperation and
assistance during the audit
thank you
commissioner Caswell do you have
anything you would like to say
I'm so commissioner Taylor Caswell uh ba
and with me is Rhonda Hensley who is our
business office manager in her
second second week on the job
um so I I would just want to first of
all thank the LBA for uh the period of
time that they have spent with us as
Christine noted we are a new agency uh
in the in the in the world of state
government and we have had
a series of individuals coming and going
through our administrative office and so
we're sort of continuing to build a
system uh to uh to move forward I would
say that the experience that we had with
the LBA was exceptionally helpful uh in
in terms of finding where we need to
improve and we're certainly already in
many of these items I think we've
already started or have addressed
it's unfortunate that when you uh and I
know the department of energy has been
through a similar situation where
legislative becomes uh and it becomes
effective on July 1st of the new fiscal
year to start a new depart government
and a lot of those pieces are not fully
in place at that exact moment in time
and we don't we don't really have a
guidebook you know how to start a new
state agency and so we we managed to uh
those first couple of months really sort
of get these pieces put together and
build an administrative system to
support the policy initiatives of the
department so overall I just I mean I
would say thank you I think we were we
were pleased with the outcome of a lot
of these uh observations and as I said
we're already working to implement
changes
as we move forward
that
okay are there questions
yes Senator gray or sorry
no
Senator Khan will uh we'll ask a
question thank you madam chair okay no
problem uh I do want to uh say something
about The Graduate retention incentive
program uh it passed uh probably four
years ago and
uh it had the endorsement of the
business industry Association of the
state it's a grow your own program
essentially to try to retain New
Hampshire graduates from New Hampshire
colleges and universities yeah in the
state for future Workforce Employment
needs uh and it costs the state very
little uh in that it's an employer
driven incentive with the administration
through the department
um I say that only as a refresher uh to
that uh I I think there the the lack of
application uh is because the it was
never uh promoted uh as an active
program so I I I'd encourage and I'd be
glad to continue to work with the
Department uh to to reignite the
partnership that was established around
the passage of that legislation
certainly Senator and and you know I
would say you know we work together to
get that legislation passed in the first
place and we did do some initial
promotional activity my recollection is
that uh we all got covered uh sort of
got in the way in the implementation of
the promotional activities and at that
point in time it was
um I think pretty difficult to make it a
huge priority given the response that
our department was involved with with
um with covid during those early months
of 2020 and into 2021.
um I think it is a good program I we
have worked with the Bia and the Bia has
new leadership in place
um the program basically allows for
businesses to provide a bonus to
individuals who
graduated from New Hampshire colleges
and to have them those businesses that
agree to do that be promoted by the
department on our website and and
interactions with with uh with our staff
so it's not necessarily a huge lift to
get that set up I think the challenge
continues to be getting the businesses
to do that and we'll we'll be working to
sort of continue to move that program
okay thanks for the response thank you
are there any further comments questions
thank you very much excellent job and uh
we'll move forward
appreciate it thank you manager
we now turn to the
audit
on the board of dental examiners office
of professional licensure and
certification
thank you madam chair this Nexus report
is a performance audit report on the
board of dental examiners in addition to
significant
dive into the office of professional
licensure and certification
the in charge on this audit it was Steve
Grady senior manager from our office
joining us from the board is Dr coacher
and from oplc is executive director
Lindsey Courtney so I'll show it over to
Steve
good morning for the record I am Steve
Grady the in charge auditor for the
Dental Board performance audit
the audit assessed how efficiently and
effectively the board administered the
regulation of dentistry and dental
hygiene in state fiscal years 2019 and
2020.
when they directly affected board
operations we also examined matters
outside that period as well as oplc and
other agencies management controls I
will be summarizing the report
but thank you you're welcome ma'am
the executive summary starts on page one
there we conclude the board lacked
adequate controls to ensure it
consistently achieved expected outcomes
and that it did so while complying with
laws rules and other requirements
the board was to protect the public
health safety and Welfare from
unqualified unscrupulous or impaired
dentists and hygienists through three
primary functions credentialing
monitoring and enforcement
however the board's regulatory program
was largely subjective
credentials that did not meet statutory
or other requirements were nonetheless
issued
ongoing credential holder qualification
was ineffectively controlled and
monitored
some seemingly significant requirements
were actually perfunctory
and Enforcement cases were
inconsistently managed and resolved
some matters were dismissed because of
insufficient support not because the
board had objectively established
non-compliance did not occur
the board lacked controls over its own
compliance with requirements it engaged
in extra legal and extra jurisdictional
activities including improperly
delegating its discretionary
decision-making Authority
creating credentials and subordinate
entities without statutory Authority
engaging in Broad ad hoc rulemaking and
failing to implement State policy
board ineffectiveness was underpinned in
part by inconsistent support from other
agencies notably the oplc
insufficient oplc management controls
adversely affected board operations in
several ways
there was no accountability framework to
ensure oplc provided services that were
acceptable and that substandard Service
delivery was remedied
records were poorly managed controls
were poorly understood
many board actions were unauditable
consequently we were compelled to
qualify our use of and our conclusions
resting on board records and
attestations
our recommendation summary follows on
page five
of the 36 observations 33 contained
board recommendations the board
concurred with 22 and concurred in part
with 11.
board recommendations primarily focus on
it ensuring expected outcomes are
achieved
rationalizing its regulatory program
actively controlling the three primary
functions
complying with laws rules and other
requirements controlling subordinate
entities and controlling the quality of
oplc services
10 observations contain oplc
recommendations that Focus primarily on
establishing an effective control
framework
complying with laws rules and other
requirements and ensuring quality
services are provided to supported
agencies
oplc management concurred with all 10.
20 observations contain either
legislative suggestions or elements that
may require legislative action depending
upon how the responsible agency
remediates the identified defects
legislative suggestions include
increasing the number of public board
members
further clarifying the oplc board
relationship or compelling them to do so
by a date certain
structuring interagency accountability
and determining whether a fundamental
change to the state's approach to
regulating occupations is warranted
current board members and oplc
management did not create all of the
defective controls we identified many
defects were long-standing
nonetheless current members and
management were responsible for
efficiency and Effectiveness it will
likely take the board several years to
address the oddest recommendations and
develop and Implement an effective
regulatory program objectively shown to
efficiently achieve expected outcomes
integration aboard and oplc controls to
help remediate some defects and gain
positive control over board operations
has reportedly begun
however whether how and when the board
will remediate other defects is
inconsistently clear
the board inconsistently recognized
limitations on its Authority
it disagreed with a need to follow some
fundamental State policy requirements
consequently we suggest the general
court consider how expanded oversight
could help ensure the board effectively
carries out State policy and that it
complies with the limitations imposed
upon it when it as it does so
I would like to thank board members
members of subordinate entities oplc
management and staff and numerous
stakeholders for their assistance during
the audit
unless there are any questions with me
I'll be followed by the board president
Dr kocher and then by Lindsey Courtney
the oplc's executive director
go ahead
uh good morning Madam chair and members
of the committee I'm Dr Punit kocher
president of the New Hampshire Board of
dental examiners and I just want to
thank you guys for letting me speak to
address the lb audit
the board does take its responsibility
to protect the public very seriously
the the fact of the matter is that none
of the board members are an attorney so
you know we count on support legal
counsel for any legislative changes that
come up
but that being said the board was
working on the current rules in place
the current legislative uh statues in
place so the Committees the LBA
committee's report was an eye-opener
so we were working with heart we were
working on what we had but since we've
had enough reading material here I think
for a few weeks or months
this is now that we realize okay now we
know better so we gotta do better so
like Steve pointed out the board is
already working on figuring out how
we're going to incorporate all these
recommendations it will be a several
years project no no doubt and it will
require resources from oplc it will
require legislative changes that the
board would reach out to maybe the
committee members or or other people who
can who can give support for those
legislative legislative changes to be
made and then we'll go from there so I'm
not going to address every observation
because I don't want you guys to spend
all your day here but if you have
questions I'll be happy to answer
I would just like to say that uh
don't feel that you were picked on
um this is probably one of our first
audits in oplc
is that correct
okay
okay yeah
can you can you hear me now yeah great
we conducted several audits in 2017
which was about two years after the OPC
was created in 2015 but since 2017 this
is the only performance audit we've
conducted of an oplc assigned agency
yeah so and that had a lot of changes at
oplc during that time
and uh so
you know they'll be uh there'll be other
boards that will be looked at in the
future
okay so you're just coming up initially
sure okay yes all right thank you thank
you
do you want to swap
thank you Dr Roger oh thank you
thank you
good morning
um for the record Lindsey Courtney I'm
the executive director of The Office of
professional licensed lice Insurance
certification
um just wanted to start out briefly by
thanking members of the auditing
auditing team team for their work in
assisting us and identifying a lot of
the issues that we've been aware of or
at least I've been aware of since
starting in 2019 but articulating it in
a fashion that I think will help us move
forward it was a long process so I I
really appreciate the work as well as
the work of the board and cooperating
and collaborating with this process oplc
completely concurs with all of the
findings in the audit and I think the
one thing that I would note is that
while this audit is specific to the
board of dental examiners the board of
dental examiners is not unique and
appeal in the concerns raised in the
audit with respect to oplc
support of the board of dental examiners
it's also applicable to all of the other
regulatory boards the experience at oplc
has been quite interesting for me in the
last two years three years almost three
there are problems that we identify
literally every day
so I wanted the committee to be aware of
that that this that while this we're
looking at the audit through the lens of
the Dental Board it does you can really
apply it to all of the support that oplc
provides to all regulatory boards
um I could go on for a long period of
time as to what I think the causes of
some of these issues are but I I will
not do so but I will say that I think
one of the primary issues as to why oplc
has not rectified its primary problem of
of having a lack of internal controls
throughout the agency is that it was not
a priority at the agency
at least for the first several years of
its Inception I can commit to you and
say to you that that is not the case
today
we have made establishing internal
controls the number one priority at the
agency
we have put that as part of our
strategic plan and I had hoped to have
copies of our strategic plan for you
today but unfortunately
we had some printer problems
um maybe that's an internal control
tissue I don't know Mr Grady would you
tell me
um but in any event
um I can commit to you that we are
committed to resolving
um the issues identified in the audit so
that we can fully support the licensing
boards the way we were designed to do so
our implementation of our strategic plan
which are is intended to remediate the
audit findings will likely take several
several years again as I noted while
these issues are specific to the Dental
Board they apply to all boards some of
the initiatives that we're currently
undertaking right now is is just
conducting an inventory of all of our
statutory and regulatory requirements
I'm sure it does not surprise most of
you that if you put all of our statutes
our practice acts in one word document
it's well over 2000 Pages that's a lot
for one agency to inventory in addition
to all of the regulatory requirements
that's just one aspect of one of the
things that we were doing
I could go on for days about the other
things that we're doing but I won't I'd
be happy to answer any questions you may
have and I'm also happy to circulate our
strategic plan to the committee after
this meeting
are there any questions
yes Senator Susie thank you
I just wonder if you
if you just identify what are the two or
three key findings that might be acted
on Pawn most quickly
or that were most troubling and need to
be acted upon most quickly
so I think the answer to that question
is going to be different for oplc versus
the Board I can say for the agency
um
most
I the biggest challenge at the agency
and I I don't know maybe Dr kotar will
agree is the lack of clarification
between board authority and
responsibility versus oplc Authority and
responsibility
um when oplc was created much like
commissioner Caswell mentioned it was
created overnight and I actually think
the budget was retroactive that year so
it was in effect without actually being
in effect
um the culture surrounding occupational
licensing was not really supportive of
the agency's creation and that's
something that has really impacted its
ability to effectively Implement its
statutory requirements it's not just a
legal change it's a cultural change that
takes a long time
that coupled with the fact that there
was probably some lack of management
going on and maybe some decisions not
made that you know to the best
um the best decisions that could have
been made I think has contributed to
um this issue but there certainly is a
lack of clarity in the legislation which
is why oplc partnered
um with I believe it was Senator Carson
last year we sought a statutory change
to or to create a study committee to
study the issue that passed so thank you
Senate Bill 330 established a study
committee the committee released its
findings I went I believe two weeks ago
stating definitively that yes there
needs to be clarification in providing a
roadmap as to how we're going to do that
so I do believe that's something the
legislature or those committee members
are interested in pursuing this
legislative session it'll probably be
the the fastest is still a solution to
one of the larger challenges we have
thank you
so I guess we identify the issues
differently one would be the functioning
like Lindsay's pointed out okay that's
the internal functioning one would be on
this on the board's performance where
the board can adequately deliver the job
it's been tasked to is is support in the
past doj was not able to provide the
board support so that was an issue oplc
had a tremendous amount of staff
turnover it was like we didn't know who
was coming and who was going so that was
an issue that has settled down because
the enforcement division has been
created by oplc we are not relying on
Doha anymore so that's a better thing
the board did not have an investigator
for quite a while
finally when we had an investigator
the agency prior to oplc had not floated
an RFA so that was debunked we could not
use that investigator anymore we had to
start over again so that was the boards
I would say the investigation side the
complaint side now from a licenses
perspective of the public protection
perspective the biggest issue we're
facing right now is is sedation that's
the biggest issue because we that was
one of the findings that came out from
the report and that was the first thing
that the board acted on so again an RFA
was loaded we've identified the people
but again they are still not ready in
the pipeline to go out and do the
investigations the board is trying to
create a committee where which we would
seek again legal legal support
legislative support for it because
the lb audit prefers everything be done
legislatively which is going to take us
even longer so we want that okay if
somebody's going to go out and do a
sedation evaluation or a sedation exam
who is making up that exam what does
that person being tested for it should
be uniform everywhere it should not be
left to The Examiner so the board is
working on securing that and figuring
that out so that is the perspective the
board has from a licensee and a public
standpoint so those are things we're
working on so I think we're waiting for
the sedation people to be in the
pipeline so they can go out and at least
do that so that's those are the biggest
requirements right now thank you Dr Q
representative leishman
I do appreciate thank you madam chair I
do appreciate the doctors will do better
comment but several hundred pages into
the document and and the LBA folks you
do an awesome job just but there was a
note about criminal background checks
to me that seems kind of up should be up
there that hasn't been conducted on
hundreds of applicants is that something
that you're going to focus on
so the criminal background checks have
been started when it was passed the
board actually had asked oplc to help
support legislation to get criminal
background checks because when the board
was doing their rules check we would say
if I as a parent has to escort my child
for any field trip I need a criminal
background check how can we have a
provider in the state who doesn't get a
criminal background check that was
passed but every time the board reached
out to oplc to see whether that had been
set in place we were told that the ball
is rolling the resources are not in
there yet they're still working on it
they have to work with the state so
nothing happened and then covet hit
so everything was on pause but now it's
it's in place it's it's the people who
who are now applying for licensure are
going through criminal background checks
thank you thank you madam chair
are there any further questions yes
speaking to uh all the rsas to deployed
oplc There's an opportunity because
if I'm continuing in division one which
I have in the past and you've been
we've met you have an opportunity in the
budgeting process to suspend regulate
rsas in in hb2 so if you've got a
burdensome level that you can't comply
with all of them rather than get getting
an audit to saying you're not complying
you can
request that these be suspended for two
years as part of the budgeting process
just to take some of the heat off
thank you that's very helpful I I think
one of the challenges
um and that that may prove to be useful
one of the challenges is that our board
practice acts with the exception of
criteria specific to a particular
licensure they all kind of say the same
thing but in different ways so you could
suspend it but you need to make sure
that we have the authority elsewhere
um it's kind of like building a fla a
plane while trying to fly it you know it
would have if it would have been nice
you know if there was clear statutory
Authority and one statute and then
um that all of the practice acts refer
to that statute instead discipline is a
set forth in each Practice Act in a
slightly different way and we're
required to implement it in a slightly
different way for all boards which is
anything but efficient so that is that
those are some of the issues that were
identified with the committee on um
established by 3 30 and we are going to
be
um you know collaborating working on
pursuing legislative changes on that but
but thank you that is something I wasn't
aware of so um I will certainly keep
that in mind representative
are there any further comments
seeing none
um
it's quarter to 12. amazing we're
getting out of here so early but that's
because I asked
Mr Carver commissioner Caswell will be
filling up some time on the second
anyhow
is there any further business I need to
worry about all right then
the meeting is adjourned
we did really well today in Virginia
getting out of here at quarter to 12.
now before this
really at one point